[Music]
did you ever think that you would be
living with these people again back in a
house back on television you know what I
had hoped for it because it's such a fun
show everyone is a star in their own
right and then once you put everyone
together it's like we speak about all
the time it's like bringing the
adventures together to save reality TV
once again obviously you've changed the
most your cast members have said that
you've said that when I was younger how
are you feeling and being two years
sober congratulations by the way that's
huge yeah twenty-eight months sober I'm
very proud it's one of my finest
accomplishments and it was a huge
challenge but it's it's a
one-day-at-a-time thing and just showing
people that it's very possible being in
that house did it trigger you at all
like what was the key in the mindset for
you the mindset was coming from a
grateful standpoint a blessed standpoint
and a stay in your lane and run your own
race because they could be drinking they
could be having fun but that's not my
race because if I look over to the
person next to me guess what I'm gonna
trip over my own feet and you gonna win
the race and the situation's not gonna
happen so I stayed in my lane Ramone
race and I challenged myself to have fun
dance and be at a club until 5 a.m. and
show people that it's possible to have
fun and you'll see because the situation
turns out more than some people do when
they're even drinkin you have a little
bit of a tough road ahead of you and EP
of the show told me that you actually
discussed the the tax evasion charges on
the show
what's your headspace at right now I
mean I discussed it to the best of my
ability you know you want to have
respect for the system the judge and and
things like that so
you know I did my best to better myself
become better and not bitter and I like
I said all if I mentioned to you but I
am the director of public outreach for a
rehab in New Jersey which I speak into
events once a month for Discovery
Institute in New Jersey to help people
that are suffering from addiction so you
know a lot of things I was facing and I
continued to better myself and I'm like
how can I you know continue to continue
to better myself and I'm like you know
let me help others so you know I'm
trying my best to take on challenges and
continue to move forward are you worried
at all about what's ahead are you at
peace with it I'm at peace with it yeah
what are people gonna be surprised to
see from you this season and what are
you a little bit anxious for people to
see I just want people to see the new
situation you know what I'm saying the
new and improved situation and you'll be
surprised when you say helping the
situation through it all his girlfriend
Lauren do you feel like she's the one oh
definitely she is the one for sure she's
been through you know good times and bad
times the ups and downs she saw me am i
worse than she deserves me at my best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]